one order of operations for starting a
startup more often than not when I talk
to a talented technical person who's
thinking about becoming a Founder their
number one blockers that they don't have
an idea at some point during their
formative years they learned that every
great startup started with a great idea
and if the idea isn't amazing usually as
judged by peers parents or other people
with little startup experience the
startup will
fail all right why'd you write I wrot
that I think I think you did WR now I
think I've read that
before I wrote this because this is the
number one excuse I hear from people who
um want to start a startup right and and
it's
so interesting to me I think that like
there are all of
these old entrepreneurial rules and
business best practices that that I
think that people just want to apply
hand and glove to a new industry M and
um I think Tech startups might be a
little different um and so interestingly
enough like I don't even think people
are really taught how to find ideas so
like I feel as though people are sitting
there saying I don't have an idea and
they don't even really understand a
process by which to get one yeah they
think they think that it's supposed to
like happen organically like it's like
almost like out of the cartoons where
like a light bulb goes off the top of
your head and like that's not really how
it works and so what I wanted to do with
this essay was give people a framework
that they could try to use to come up
with an idea so instead of this being a
passive process can be active process I
think one of the things that like might
be hard for people to see is like now
being in this world for so long I have a
lot of friends who wanted to do a
startup and didn't know what they wanted
to do and then came up with an idea and
were very successful and so like I've
seen this happen with a lot of people
and so that's kind of where I've come up
with this thought MH so you break it out
into one two three four uh several steps
so this is I'm going to outline and then
we can explain so the order of
operations here's where I'd start is
there any particular problem that you're
passionate about the next step once you
decide on a problem find some friends
and brainstorm potential solutions to
the problem the next step at this point
the most important thing uh to make that
spark turn into a fire is to work
together and build and launch an MVP yes
and that's basically it yeah yeah it's
not that complex no it's hard but it's
not that complex no it's not so so let's
start at the beginning uh particular
passion problem your passion about um so
I think often
times I'll give you the conversation
that I had with um with a Founder I was
at a conference over the weekend called
afrotech and there a bunch of young
people who wanted to start companies
there and this woman walked up to me and
she said I have an idea um I'm doing a
startup that helps other startups
and um I call this like a meta startup
and and this is startups that I kind of
don't like because it's
like in some ways I think it's like a
cop out it's like hey I'm giving I want
to help give other startups advice and
guidance but I haven't really done a
startup myself and like it's I don't
know it's just it's it's it's not great
and so I dug in I was like okay so
what's a problem that you have and um it
was interesting so the woman was the
mother and she said one of the problems
I had have is that
um I there are a lot of places when I go
somewhere new there are a lot of places
where I don't know if I can use my
stroller with my baby because it's like
hard to get around or if I'm walking on
a street does it have you know the
proper sidewalks and so and so forth so
I'd love like some type of product that
would like tell me
um what path I should take that's like
stroller friendly and I said to her okay
that's but we're getting somewhere right
now we're not we're not in like this
meta idea now we're actually solving
problem directly great but I I I asked
her hey can you judge this by two um
things first one how frequent is this
problem MH and she said well actually
when I'm in an area that I know then I
know where to walk I know how to do it
it's not that fre and how intense is
this problem it's like well you
know if I have to go over a curb or
something you know it's like it's a it's
pain but it's not like you know so then
I was like okay what if you could start
a problem that was addressing one of the
top three problems in your life what
would it be and you know what she said
she said affordable child care I like
you know what a lot of people have that
problem that's a big problem and like I
felt my like douchebag investor like
light go off it's like yes you should do
that like that is a problem like even if
you have solved that problem you're
going to be wildly successful like there
are gajillions people have that problem
it's ridiculously intense it's like and
it was like interesting because in such
a weird way I feel like she had somehow
condensed all of the startup advice that
she'd been given and everything she read
to go to this like wrong place when I
just asked her what's the problem in
your life and she almost immediately got
to like a place that could create real
value now like how should she solve that
problem okay yes that's another question
but damn like it's a personal problem
she has and she sure as hell knows that
if she makes a product is it helping her
yeah and at least if it's helping her
she knows it's like halfway decent so
like that I got to a really exciting
place by just digging into like what
sucks for you I think everyone can do
that exercise and I think that like that
exercise can be informed by your work
life or your personal life so many
startups I see were created because they
were doing something at work and they
were like this sucks why do I have to
keep on doing this yeah I'm going to
make this thing and then sell it to my
job so that no one has to do this ever
again right um so it can apply either
way right and this is a very easy way to
get people to pay you whereas doing
things like strapping a webcam to your
head not as obvious not as obvious of a
problem pretty pretty non
obvious so all right so so you go there
yeah so once you find a problem find
some friends and brainstorm potential
solutions to the problem so here's the
trick
um you don't need to skip to a solution
too early MH and your thought process
should be whatever solution I come up
with is probably going to be wrong so my
solution really is is a first
hypothesis and basically it's like
imagine I'm trying to
um I don't know like redo some famous
science experiment like I'm trying to
figure out the speed of gravity or
something right um I first have to start
with hypothesis then test and then
repeat repeat repeat and play to my
answer okay so
um I don't need to know the answer up
front like that's not the goal if you
have a big enough problem like trust
that like if you come up with anything
resembling an answer in a reasonable
period of time years yeah you have a big
business
so instead of thinking okay let me come
with my idea how to solve it I think the
more important thing is to start talking
to other people about it because I think
that the number one thing you have to do
to create a company or one of the top
three is to have some co-founders and
it's really
helpful to figure out who who are the
types of people who you can talk to
about something and you riff well you
you iterate each other's ideas there's
sometime people you brainstorm with and
like they say like I say Craig wouldn't
it be cool if the sky is red and Craig
says no and that's the end of the
brainstorm right it's like well we might
out have a best found relationship right
as opposed to like well wouldn't it be
cool if the sky was red and Craig says
you know we can't make the sky R but
what happens if we like tint all the
windows in the house red so you can make
it look like this guy's red it's like oh
yeah right you know like we're moving
right so you want to start having those
conversations with people that you like
um people if you're not technical people
who are technical um people who you dis
respect their intelligence
and ideally together you start coming up
with an idea and what's cool about that
is that if you come up with that idea
together um everyone you've been talking
to feel some ownership of the idea yeah
and that helps kind of light that flame
yeah yeah it's dangerous to be married
to a solution yeah yes that a real
problem all right so at this point the
most important thing is to turn that
spark into a fire and work together to
build an MVP boom so biggest mistake
that people make at this point is to
think that the things they need to do is
like now I feel like some like weird
Phantom MBA starts whispering in their
ear and it's like you need to
incorporate you need to raise money you
need to and it's like kick that person
out that person like that's not it's not
what you need to do can you just build a
simple V1 of the product can you build
the simplest V1 even if it's just an
Excel spreadsheet something powered by
an Excel spreadsheet give it a try like
the way to get that team even more
excited is to try something yeah and
like often times I see people kind of
get lost in that legal or that
fundraising world and never even got to
give their thing a try you don't need U
you don't need like bank accounts to
give something a try you don't need an
incorporation to give something a try
for the most part there's some ideas you
do but like for the most part you don't
um and a way that you can really get
that team solidified is just to get some
kind of MVP and get like one customer
two customers um this is one the final
test on like hey can we work together
well right and two man it amps up the
excitement a lot and so that when you
have to go through some of the [__]
of incorporation and stuff yeah or
fundraising right the excitement level
is high yeah um also third it gives you
leverage like if you actually have
something with a couple customers then
like investors are far more interested
to like to talk to you than if you just
have an idea especially people who are
on the fence about working with you yes
I mean these are all of these things
that you're saying these are all excuses
you create because it's easier than
working on the actual
problem well yes for some people but I
also think it's for some people it's
what they think is the right path it's
like it's like I actually think that
some people some people are being I
don't want to say lazy but some people
are
being I don't know
um not some people are kind of being
disingenuous in this process but I think
other people actually think oh no the
right thing to do is actually to come up
with an idea fund raise Outsource an MVP
and then hire a team like I think that
like some people think that's the right
thing to do and it's
like harder that's a harder path okay
like you don't have to do that well my
failure mode is different then um all
right so so then uh you WRA this essay
up with a couple things the two failed
orders of operations well these are two
of many I suppose yes um so one come up
with an idea and then pitch to investors
yes two I have an idea but can't write
code and none of my co-founders can
either yeah so
um we're in a time where there are a lot
of startups and there's um unfortunately
you're people that you're pitching if
they're good they're getting pitched by
a lot of people so you need to bring
some real fire to that meeting yeah and
uh a good deck is no longer good enough
um I would argue that back in the day
like in the 90s it was so expensive to
get sophomore made and hosted and online
and get users that like a good deck or
actually back then it was like a 100
page business plan like that's all you
could get that's all you could do
without money um we're not there now and
so um you're not bringing the fire if
you're just bringing an idea now some
people can raise on just an idea right
and if you're one of those lucky people
that's great but like I don't know like
I rather be good than
lucky um in terms of you know no
technical co-founders like this is a
constant issue and I'm surprised by this
like I talked to a friend the other day
who is thinking about starting something
and doesn't have a technical co-founder
yet and even she was a little concerned
about getting one even though she has
kind of been in the tech startup world
and and you know I had to encourage her
I had to tell her no you can like you
can do this like it's not it's it's it's
not not only is it's not going to be
that hard it's that like it's probably
going to be easier than Outsourcing it
um the one favor Moe that I see a lot is
that I see people who can raise a little
bit of
money go down the Outsourcing route and
believe that they are progressing they
believe that the thing is moving forward
and what they don't realize is that for
the most part they're going to need to
iterate anything that's created by those
outsourcers over and over and over and
over again and it gets pretty expensive
pretty fast and so the fa remote that I
see so constantly is
outsourcing iterating with that
outsourcers you run out of money yeah
you haven't figured things out yet and
so you have to go to an investor and say
well I don't have anything I need more
money and like that's death and like
what's so sad about that death is that
like you've been kind of walking that
path the whole time but often you don't
realize it to the very end and after you
spent money and like sometimes it's
people's own money like they do their
savings they hand their savings to these
people and like I don't think the
Outsourcing folks are are bad or morally
morally wrong um I just think that like
people should take the hustle that they
have and apply it to the number one
problem which is
like it just turns out that getting a
technical co-founder tends to be cheaper
than paying an outsourcer yeah yeah I
mean I guess you know to push back if
you had someone Outsource something and
then that got you a couple customers
then you found a co-founder that's a
great outcome well it's interesting
because I think that a lot of people go
into the
Outsourcing um route with that yeah um
intention but the thing that they don't
realize is that like they didn't feel
comfortable going and find technical
co-founder now when they don't have any
traction and they don't have a product
right most likely the outcome is the
outsourcer will give them a shitty
product a shitty V1 totally y they won't
have any users then and now they'll go
after Technic co-founder with a shitty
product and no users and less money like
and they want to give the co-founder 10%
yeah like they're not actually in a
better position so it's like like yes I
think that they're like one and I and I
I mentioned the essay there are counter
examples like there are people who do go
from a contractor to big company but
it's just I would argue it's a harder
path and it's a um path that's much more
likely to lose you a lot of money your
own money your own money take